salve a tutti ragazzi e per minchia
l'ascella
ed oggi ragazzino non può che non lo
facevo siamo tornati su wei lu press di
barun il fatto che ogni volta che vedo
sto videogame mi viene da giocarlo
perché ti fa domande tipo luke gottwald
words and to come cazzo fai a dire di no
il gioco ti mette davanti a due
condizioni una positiva e una negativa e
tu premendo il bottone accetti entrambe
le condizioni lo spiegato da cani però
non fa niente in questo caso new king of
lovers quindi puoi andare ad hogwarts ma
am bridge e la preside che a bridge è
questa qua che praticamente è diventata
preside dopo che dal ministro della mai
una [ __ ] è una [ __ ] quindi sì lo farei
lo stesso a costo che mi berna frusta
mid [ __ ] diventeresti milionario ma
l'unica musica che potresti ascoltare
sarebbe smash mouth all star e che cazzo
è ma scusate devo documentarmi in atti
[Musica]
non so scarso delle parole ma hey hey ya
konan e bellissimo sì sì e vi dirò di
più oltre che l'ambrì germi ascolto
oppure sono sta canzone è al 100 di
andare alla guerra potresti uccidere
chiunque tu voglia ma ogni volta ci sarà
un 10 per cento di possibilità di
uccidere qualcuno a cui tieni ma io sto
potere già cielo quindi sono a posto
[Musica]
cazzo devo finire presto questo video
devo scappare veloce in tibet la persona
che ami diventerebbe felice in eterno ma
tu diventeresti depresso in eterni o per
la persona che amo fare i farei anche
questo fare questo ed altro ma
[ __ ] assolutamente no ma seconda
certo che no ma che siamo a scalzare io
dove sono depresso vada [ __ ]
potresti conoscere qualsiasi cosa
riguardo l'universo la sua creazione i
suoi misteri ma non potresti dirlo a
nessun altro ma assolutamente sì me lo
tengo per me piuttosto va benissimo
potresti essere in grado di entrare in
tre mondi diversi a tua scelta ad
esempio harry potter supernatural
assassin's creed eccetera ma più ci stai
dentro più ti dimentichi della tua vita
originale da dove proviene ma rava
angulo assolutamente sì tutti hanno
premuto sto bottone potesse avere soldi
infiniti ma saresti sono sveglio per
quattro ore al giorno ma io ho già dormo
20 ore al giorno per che però facciamo
lì non potresti diventare invisibile
quando vuoi ma quando sei invisibile 6
anche cieco ma che cazzo se ne frega se
in un'interrogazione diventa invisibile
vi se ne frega se sei cieco finisce la
lezione sentire la campanella e torni
visibile non potessi capire tutte quante
le emozioni espresse una per una
ma non saresti in grado di esprimerne
una tua cioè tipo kristen stewart quindi
no boh non lo so sposeresti la persona
perfetta ho finalmente una persona alla
quale dare il mio amore ma tu vivrai per
sempre l'altra persona no quanto
sentimentali ragazzi e sti cazzi ce li
metti io dovrò vedere tutte le future
puntate di game of thrones per
l'eternità foto e sega che di chi muore
keane umore puoi essere la persona più
felice di tutto il mondo ma tutti gli
altri sul pianeta moriranno come me mi
sorge uno sticazzi mi sorge uno sticazzi
da 300 no va bene sto scherzando
ovviamente sto scherzando
il tuo computer è immune ai virus ed
evasore che conosci inclusi i tuoi amici
dei familiari hanno accesso alla tua
cronologia internet che sia cancellata o
meno così mio padre sa che mi guardo i
porno norvegesi con il milf bionde no
bene puoi diventare visibile quando vuoi
ma ogni volta che diventa invisibile di
vecchi mille volte più velocemente vabbè
basta non usarlo mai e lo usi nel
momento del bisogno quando ci sono le
interrogazioni uscire la classe che c'è
in 80 anni ma almeno ho mai preso un 4
di segnare sti estremamente bene ma non
saresti mai notato per questo talento
vaio disegno come una capra muffita
quindi direi di sì va bene perché cazzo
esplosa ma nucleare qual è il problema
questa cosa perché cazzo esplosione
nucleare qualcuno me lo spiega grazie va
bene cos'è successo puoi vivere
nell'universo che preferisci ma non puoi
interagire con niente in esso pensate
trovarsi una bella [ __ ] spaziale non
poter neanche dare una toccatina
no la scuola è cancellata per sempre
scuola perfetto ma non puoi dormire per
più di otto ore al giorno mai a malapena
dr mons né dormo 6 ma sì la scuola è
bella la fine minchia tutti i miei amici
puoi essere la star del tv show che
preferisci ma devi avere un tatuaggio di
con su scritto isle of justin bieber
bene diresti sempre la cosa giusta ma un
pasto al mese saprà di merda di cane e
tu dovrai finirlo spiegatevi che cazzo
di problemi aveva chi ha creato questa
domanda c'è qualcosa che vorresti dirmi
di qualche problema di cui vorresti
parlarmi perché ce n'hai qualcuno non lo
so ma che cazzo ne so io va bene la
riciclato progetto ha detto no
impareresti a lanciare delle palle di
fuoco non puoi giocare a videogame per
il resto della tua vita ma chi cazzo se
ne frega faccia il gameplay per strada
figata uguale le puoi guardare qualsiasi
film un mese prima che esca in qualità
top spoiler me una volta che l'hai visto
dovrei vedere una volta al giorno per un
mese e magari no potresti vivere per
sempre tutti quanti ti ho direbbero che
cazzo se ne frega tanto muoiono tutti io
rimango vivo
[Applauso]
la vj moriva affogato da una bottiglia
d'acqua avresti l'abilità di succhiare
la sede ma non sono una 2000
scherzavo avresti l'abilità di succhiare
la tristezza fuori dalle persone
lasciando soltanto felicità e gentilezza
alle tue spalle ma dovresti tenere tutta
la tristezza dentro di te per il resto
della tua vita e non puoi ucciderti
comunque si 50 per cento di chance di
ricevere il 100 mila dollari 50 per
cento di chance di perdere un unghia
notizia cento è un unghia simin l'unghia
del dito non lo farei solo ed
esclusivamente per il fatto che sono
incredibilmente sfigato e mi uscirebbe
per forza questa quindi no graf ancora
potresti avere la ragazza dei tuoi sogni
selena mia
selena mia se ne va mio cosa devo fare
per averti selena cosa devo fare un tuo
amico muore non me ne frega un cazzo
giorgio muori muori forte iorio attento
quando attraversi la strada attentissimo
quindi potrebbe passare un camion
fortissimo avere ragazzi direi che basta
per oggi perché sto gioco sto gioco è
una droga ma ma serio è veramente una
droga io andrei avanti tutto il giorno a
cliccare tasti però se lo faccio non
posso montare il video quindi non lo
vede neanche mia nonna e sti cazzi
quindi ragazzi miei spero che video vi
sia piaciuto non mi piace per selena
gomez che diventerà la mia ragazza dopo
questo scusano cose da ragazzi mi è
piaciuto questo momento mi piace anche
la pagina di facebook e come nevi
adottata nelle scrizione senatore si
descrive temi ci rivediamo cose ci ha
messo anche un ora e mezzo a cadere vive
interessino youtuber da 3 milioni di
iscritti ma non saresti più in grado di
afferrare un telecomando io ho
schiacciato sì che poi ragazzi il velo
che sotto telecomando lo ridotto così
non sapete quante volte è ancora
funziona solo rimonto spero stavolta
qualche l'ho detto non funziona più
scommettere se lo senti di schiavini ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi